جاءتها بثت السلطات دنيت المواليه لروسيا
سورا قالت انها تعود للسيطره قواتها على
مواقع اوكرانيه في منطقتي زبرجير ويظهر
المقطع والمصور انتشار جنود من قوه دونيتك
في خنادق ضمن اراد زراعيه تقول القوات
الموليه لروسيا انها سيطرت عليها خلال
المعارك الاخيره
في هذه الاثناء دعا رئيسه الاوكراني الذي
نزل نيسكي الشركاء بلاده لتوفير فرصه
حقيقيه
لحمايه فعاله للاجواء الاوكرانيه في
مواجهه الضربات الروسيه المتعدده
نحو سته ملايين اوكرانيا
الله يتركهم اليوم
الاصلاح المستمره بلا توقف منذ الهجوم
الارهابي الاخير هناك مشاكل في امدادات
التدفئه ومشاكل اكبر في امدادات المياه
اصعب الاوضاع هي في كيب وبنيتا والفيفا
الشركاء الاعزاء نبحث عن فرصه لتوفير
حمايه فعاله اوكرانيا
موثوق بها يوم توفير الحمايه لشعبنا
وبنسبه 100% من الضربه الروسيه الارهابيه
عندما يحدث ذلك فان طريقه الرئيسيه
للارهاب الروسي الصاروخي ستصبح مستحيله